hello this is matthew with simply learn
and let's dig
into how devops which is developers and
operators
working together is the key for
successful
continuous delivery so devops is
as an evolution of the agile model the
agile model really is great
for gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out
your solutions and what we want to be
able to do is kind of address that
challenge and that gap between
the ops team and the dev team and so
with devops what we're doing is
bringing together the operations team
and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then
work more seamlessly together because
they are integrated
to be able to build out solutions that
are being tested
in a production-like environment so that
when we actually deploy
we know that the code itself will work
the operations team
is then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment
and being able to provide feedback to
the developers
on what is being successful so we're
able to make
adjustments in our code that it's based
on data
so let's step through the different
phases of a devops team so typically
you'll see that the devops team will
actually have eight phases now this is
somewhat similar
to agile and what i'd like to point out
at time is that again
agile and devops are very closely
related
that agile and devops are closely
related
delivery models that you can use with
devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases
so the first phase is planning and this
is where we actually sit down with a
business team and we go through and
understand what their goals
are the second stage is as you can
imagine and this is where it's all very
similar to agile is that the coders
actually start coding
but they typically they'll start using
tools such as git
which is a distributed version control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working
on the same code base rather than bits
of the code that is rather than them
working on bits of the code that they
are responsible for so the goal with
using tools such as git
is that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as maven and
gradle
as a way to consistently build out your
environment
and then we also use tools to actually
automate our testing now what's
interesting is when we use tools like
selenium and junit is that we're moving
into a world
where our testing is scripted the same
as our build environment
and the same as using our get
environment we can start scripting
out these environments and so we
actually have scripted production
environments that we're
moving towards jenkins is the
integration
phase that we use for our tools and
another pointer here is that the tools
that we're listing here these are all
open source tools these are tools that
any team
can start using we want to have tools
that control and manage the deployment
of code into the production environments
and then finally
tools such as ansible and chef will
actually operate
and manage those production environments
so that when code comes to them that
that code is compliant with the
production environment so that when
the code is then deployed to the many
different production
servers that the expected results of
those servers which is you want them to
continue running
is received and then finally you monitor
the
entire environment so you can actually
zero in
on spikes and issues that are relevant
to
either the code or changing consumer
habits on the site
so let's step through some of those
tools that we have in the devops
environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have
and again one of the things i want to
point out is that these tools
are open source tools there are also
many other tools this is just really a
selection of some of the more popular
tools that are being used but it's quite
likely that you're already using some of
these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using
git but some of the other tools really
help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start
scripting out your entire devops
toolset this really helps when it comes
to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing
the more effective you can be at running
automation against
those scripts and the more effective you
can be at having a consistent
experience so let's step through this
devops process
so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to
make a release well the first thing you
want to do is send out your
files to the build environment and you
want to be able to test
the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the
all the way through to the production
environment because we're testing all of
that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can
send that code right back to the
developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix
that with information that is real on
the
either the code or the production
environment
if however your code passes the the
scripting test
it can then be deployed and once it's
out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment
what this provides you is the
opportunity to
speed up your delivery so you go
from the waterfall model which is weeks
months or even years between releases
to agile which is two weeks or four
weeks depending on your
sprint cadence to where you are today
with devops where you can actually be
doing multiple releases
every single day so there are some
significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are
really zeroing in on those advantages
if we take any one of these companies
such as
google google any given day will
actually
process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on youtube that you can find out
on how their devops teams
work netflix is also a similar
environment
now what's interesting with netflix is
that netflix have
really fully embraced devops within
their
development team and so they have a
devops team and
netflix is a completely digital company
so
they have software on phones on smart
tvs
on computers and on websites
interestingly though
the devops team for netflix is only 70
people
and when you consider that a third of
all internet traffic on any given day
is from netflix it's really a reflection
on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire
business with just 70 people so there
are some key advantages that devops has
it's the actual time to create and
deliver software is dramatically
reduced particularly compared to
waterfall complexity and maintenance is
also reduced because you're automating
and scripting out your entire
environment
you're improving the communication
between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together
and that there is continuous integration
and continuous delivery
so that your consumer your customer is
constantly
being delighted so hopefully this was of
benefit to you today
if it was please like and subscribe
below leave any comments and we'll get
back to you thanks very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here